hello everybody tyler's here say hi
hi it's me tyler this is the first time
they've seen you in a video in a while
and that's all you say
you literally last time i talked more
and you're like don't do that
i say that when did i say that
oh you know in that podcast when you're
like they know who you are they know who
you are well at that point they should
and if you don't know what we're talking
about tyler and i we have a new podcast
what's it called tyler it's called go my
favorite sports team and you can listen
to it right now immediately through the
link in the description below
there is a link to
a podcast service that we have picked
that you can see listen
tyler take over please yes uh you can
find the podcast by searching go my
favorite sports team or clicking the
link in the description but you can
search go my favorite sports team on
spotify apple google and amazon to find
uh a place that fits your listening
needs so what we're gonna do today is
something that we did similar uh in
2017. tyler and i we played the super
bowl the super bowl game the super bowl
the
in that game where you could play
football it's madden who um uh was the
innovator for sports video games in a
lot of ways um john madden did pass away
this year so
uh rest in peace mr man in honor of uh
of the super bowl and mr madden himself
uh i have this here let me share my
screen i've got the super bowl game here
uh
uh
i'm very confused why i'm looking at
cabal vision and
what looks like a vampire and a giant
ogre sitting at a desk what are you
talking about
that's john madden look man i don't know
what to tell you i saw this game on
steam it was on sale i wasn't gonna pay
full price for that other game and i
figure one football game is the same as
another right
plus i went in here and there's already
the teams loaded in oh yeah so we got
the bangles with their lineup you know
they're yellow oh change their color
make them orange it is orange what are
you talking about that looks like yellow
that is the orangest orange
oh my god no no no it's them it's let's
see the bangles who day
team roster
we got joe burrow we got bo giro jamar
chase
he tiggens t higgins josh
sam hubbard ham suburb majar chase
cj uzoma jc ozoma bj uzoma jp uzoma joe
mixon mo dixon and double x uzoma we got
them all it's all here
they're at the paul bronze stadium
[Laughter]
you know we got the red we got wait no
we got wait hold on go back go back to
where you just were hold on there's
there's a selection for cheerleader when
you're looking at oh bro
it says human versus cheerleader
that's just human cheerleaders it could
be dwarf cheerleaders or otherwise
what we're gonna do there's no way to
get these teams to play like ai against
each other so i will play as the bengals
and you commentate you know this game in
and out wait you're playing
yeah i'm playing what why are you
laughing
you're playing
what do you mean i have their playbook
right here i will play as them i know
what i'm doing
do you yeah
what are you
saying i don't know what i'm doing i
last time we played we played madden
and you just were like hail mary every
player this is madden this is i don't
know what to tell you
welcome back sportsman oh boy
oh we're playing that paul braun yeah
where else is super bowl super bowl's
played at uh la stadium this year well
look
you need every advantage you can get
i'll let you i'll let you do it hey come
on man you don't know how he's gonna go
look at this lineup of beautiful bangles
oh yeah 12 13 7.
mm-hmm
why do they all why are they rodents
look how giant they are
you didn't even fit
the other team is so much bigger no what
do you that's fine
look size is in everything size is not
everything i'm sorry but she lied to you
set up your team all right so how should
i set up
you got a solid solid defense right now
what are your options i can move them
no
uh put your big guy in the middle right
in the middle of that that's right oh
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point
i think you're lined up pretty good now
like that
yeah all right let's see what happens
all right
oh i'm kicking i think you want to kick
it
there yeah i think that's a good spot
just just short of the
the end zone there so blitz
defense start their drive a fraction of
a second before the offense is ready
catching their opponents by surprise all
right uh give me give me you you are a
commentator in this game you give me a
constant bl play-by-play translate the
action to what's happening here sure so
far you got big big josh to tofu lined
up right in the center ready to
completely rip off the head of the the
opposing goat that's
somehow smaller than the giant rat
meanwhile small rats are going against
giant goats and they're going to really
nibble their way through that offensive
line uh-huh
what am i doing
you should uh i don't know how to play
this game so i have no clue i can't you
can't remember
you already performed it actually oh
wait no sorry i just needed to
the ball
oh gotcha here they go
oh they're they're going around to the
left here
looks like they're gonna run it a wild
animal
all right he's going to cover that edge
um you need to you need to cover that
end on the the the left-hand side when
you left-hand side
he's going to run back and get the ball
he dropped it he dropped it he turned
the ball over look at that you're
already winning mark we got um we got uh
who's this we got no don't run him that
far don't run no oh god
i did not make it guys it didn't matter
yeah
yeah
i was worried about that yeah so what's
that like when uh you get your uh gutter
runner tripped over as he's going for
the ball that's an absolute pancake
block if i've ever seen one
ah i don't know what just happened
he picked up the ball and he's running
forward all right all right cool take
your big login dude in the center well
it's not my turn he's gonna take he's
gonna take out your dude from behind
there
nice dodge
he dodged his block
he's going to shed defenders all right
see that big guy in the middle when it's
your turn oh yeah yeah yeah i know i
know what you're talking about yeah you
send him deep in there to attack that
boy oh
he's trying to
delete your man oh
it's a epic hit of jokes no mix it no
i gotta use my
apothecary revive him oh he's stunned
he'll get up next turn
that's better than dead
stunned is better than dead
in football oh oh god oh my god another
one obliterated by the rams offensive
line yeah that was uh that was silver
cup with a big hit along with his uh
compatriot odell beckham senior really
little okay and he was ready with that
dodge yeah von miller won some but ham
suburb wasn't having none of it we got
odell beckham the third over here
looking off and jamar chase he knows
they're going for your big logging boy
i think you need to take out the guy in
front of to topu all right let's let's
uh let's uh let's see what he does
poopoo versus aaron o'donnell aaron
donald very strong we know he's strong
okay oh both people down
they just butted heads like we've never
seen before in a blood bath
we got it down on the field i think
you're gonna have to start uh moving
that man right there this guy
no he's gonna be moved a little bit
he needs to move
back
all right he'll move
that's your heely boy and he's down
no that's not the apothecary that was
joe burrow and joe burrows out for the
exclamation point
he missed completely a big whiff oh
that's too bad that's too bad
oh and a double knockout again von
miller is stunned
all right
that guy right there whatever his name
is who's next to the stun boy go get
ball why is he going that way jump over
okay i don't know
i think you got to make him wider i
think he's got to go to that minus one
spot
all right i think i think that's where
you go then
let's see there we go that's better yeah
all right so i think in this game if you
get knocked unconscious the other team
just gets to go oh yeah all right there
there's a chance for your man right
there
all right so there man doesn't take him
out so is this a coaching problem or is
this a player's not putting in enough
hey i think this is definitely a
coaching problem i think
i think the alignment was a little poor
in deciding where they wanted to uh to
go all right
i think this time the defense has a
chance using
the man
not next to an opposing defender no
it'll be fine it'll be fine it'll be
fine it'll be fine nope uh no wait wait
yeah yeah there you go there we go this
is what we're looking for oh he oh he
does he's too quick he's got a chance
he's got a chance he's going for the
chance he's getting that's team re-roll
i think that's a win
i think that's a bad win t higgins is
down for the count there seems to be a
clear indication that there's uh
unfairness in terms of the amount of
players they can move versus the amount
of players the bengals can move i think
it ultimately comes down to if you get
knocked unconscious
you can no longer move that turn you're
right but these guys are two f a two
fear induced jamar chase and majar chase
majar chase the chase brothers are gonna
are gonna be the saviors of the bengals
here on defense i can tell we can all
tell that that is true man never mind i
think he always just scored the
touchdown anyway he slips he slips at
the one yard line and dies
he is a dead he's rewinding time
and he oh dang it with an effective
rewind of time he has a rewritten
history and uh that touchdown will count
apparently in this version of football a
touchdown is only one point ah break out
the cheer wow
my god the cheerleaders with their
man-eating heads wow i didn't need to
see that that is a memory i will not get
burned out of my brain in any time soon
i think uh i think he's he's he's doing
an interesting decision here
he's got to dodge a defender
to get to the ball
yeah no matter what he's got to get to
that ball for sure and then uh if he
goes this way he's got to dodge a lot of
things got to get a plus four year plus
three there plus five there and plus
he's gotta be the luckiest uh set of the
[ __ ] on the plays of the year you know
i think the pluses mean he has he's got
a pretty good chance there he in fact
took out
he's cleaning
he made it through whoa do not pass that
over there let's see what happens we'll
see if he goes here he just needs a plus
four and a plus three if he goes this
route he needs a plus five if he goes
straight down the barrel he needs a plus
five seems like this seems to be his
best bet let's see what's like the best
chance yeah let's see what happens
he's tripped
but time is on his side
perhaps
perhaps the replay will not be instantly
what it is right in the ass oh
oh
dang
oh and that's uh halftime
apparently so you know i never expected
uh football to be a turn-based game but
i
it seems you know that kind is the case
uh they do call plays
uh between downs and uh then then run it
out yeah you're right but uh usually
both teams go at the same time that
seems like a rough decision because he's
gonna have to dodge and then hurt
somebody you're right that's a terrible
yeah let's just hurt somebody we we're
really looking to hurt people here
uh what is that defender down like that
i like the sound of that yeah apparently
you get a choice of what happens
oh look at that bite but
he just ate him up
oh red why is it red
defender stumbles
hmm
i don't know oh boy
yeah that's that's the they both hurt
each other uh die apparently maybe if we
had known the rules of this particular
version of football we might have a
chance probably big guy needs the guy in
front of big guy needs to be taken out
first you're right he do
never mind
oh no there's an opportunity to get a
knock down here by clicking on the
knockdown dice no if it's red you can't
click any of them simply uh
impossible you do have another guy that
can take out a different dude
uh we're gonna just here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna we're gonna wild
animal this guy and then pass over here
and if there's no one alive
why is that how that goes finally after
they boxed everything out they have
created a nice safe space for themselves
however they didn't count on uh
this happening well that's not gonna
happen
this happening nope
okay not that either
i think possibly taking out the people
around the ball instead of the ball
initially might be the play here now you
see the thing is they seem to all be red
they're all very red
ah
death attacker down no oh skull is bad
oh you these you see how one might think
in football that skull would be good it
turns out
not every time you chose
one second here we got some uh
interference going on with this uh with
uh with um we got some interference
interference there's interference right
now
there's interference right now where it
would uh
i think there's some static coming in i
i think it's static i think static
something
bad has happened yeah it's a shame you
hate to see it uh you really hate to see
it this is what i was looking for
now hold on
ah it's perfect
it's perfect i'm excited for the
perfection that i shall witness finally
all right
now we've had some uh problems with our
broadcast i'd like to bring out the real
bangles the uh previous bengals were uh
imposters to say the least see we got
the real bangles here ah yes
got the real bangles here
all right ball brown stadium now we're
really gonna see this let's see make the
past hour of recording like into like 10
minutes
[Laughter]
by the way what tyler what do you have
to say to the lovely people out there by
the way guys if you want to learn about
real sports or just hear mark figure
things out in
the most interesting way imaginable
uh you should check out the podcast
called go my favorite sports team uh
it's in all the podcast locations it's
our podcast not just the podcast
but it's also their podcast oh look at
this guy
i think that's joe burrow
[Laughter]
uh look at these the rams pathetic
creatures all right looks like the
advantage here is having these three
huge guys let's just go ahead and bring
him up here i want to get a nice
competition here where we're uh just
going to slam our faces together
we're just going to match up against the
the d.c
that's what i'm hoping for
and uh in doing so we're going to really
give ourselves a right opportunity to
start this off well and here's the kick
from the rams kick
oh nice gentle gust of wind has affected
the game bouncing the ball
direct center of the field and we're
gonna just absolutely devastate everyone
here
let's see what happens
and the big
am cakers
absolutely obliterated completely chaot
unavailable till the end of the match
y'all you hate to see it you just hate
to see it
oh well what could happen again
oh another knock down this time
the angles really take out that left
side
for their offense yeah they are really
cleaning up the place let's see what
happens with joe burrow against cam
akers here
joe really is number one he is number
one and oh
to the gut
to the groin
oh that looked like a stomach hit to me
but i'll oh
re-roll that one uh
i think pushing him back is the right
decision here pushing back is the right
decision let's see uh the fall through
on that one
let's just take this
and that's gonna be a nice hit that's
gonna be a quality hit wow
that guy ain't gonna be moaning no more
all right let's set up dude are we ready
beautiful
oh yeah they're beautiful all right oh
that's a good hit
for a second i thought he was going to
use this rear end to really knock the
noggin off of that one yeah i thought so
too i think we all thought that
and it's another hit
this time with a hard left hand this is
bessie james really got the best of
the uh
the offense there yeah all right we're
gonna we got uh
all right here comes a risky pass here
coming in hot and that's the biggest
whiff i've ever seen in my life see it
really would have been beneficial if
they used joe burrow for that play
he was laying the hurt down i guess the
rams a perfect opportunity to just oh
we fumbled it
all right he's going to blitz this one
oh
god that had to hurt
but there the replay may give him a
second chance here
no it didn't not he's just down he's
just as down as he was before if not
more if not more
damn really unfortunate
for the bengals here yeah it is
unfortunate they seem to have entirely
forgot about the possibility of actually
using a ball
oh and those teammates are getting back
up getting back up the rams are
resilient if anything
they are that look at him go and all
that work might just be [ __ ] wasted
because it's just a completely open spot
to there
oh my microphone seems to be
experiencing some interference
oh boy this is what we'd love to see
i am just so
it seems that when the bengals attempt
to cheat they lose however when the
patriots attempt to cheat they
absolutely destroy the competition here
you know it's funny you say cheat
there's no cheating going on here it's
just uh entirely valid god damn it it's
entirely valid and very smart playing
uh
on the bangles
and oh that's good
right to the balls oh
head first to the balls
all right we're gonna
see what we can do here and yep this is
what we love to see
oh
sony mitchell is out sony mitchell
there needs to be a better defense to
prevent the rams from moving the ball up
field maybe there's a mango player that
can get in the way
yeah you might be right about that let
me look there might be this one
here comes joe burrow joe burrow is
marching
yeah he's just going to stare him down
because he knows if he he moves at an
inch he's got to go through the both of
them that don't look good that don't
look brown another player that could
potentially get into that spot as well
yeah you probably right about that you
probably right you know i wonder if they
can get actually in between their uh
their offensive player and the end zone
yeah they might they might they just
might
in a in a moment
oh
oh
no it's fine
oh oh
oh god
oh god
ouch the bengals lose a player no they
don't he's just stunned that's how tough
he is
that's incredible
i know you know
the bengals have really fought hard this
entire season
and the rams have as well the rams
believe it or not have played all of
their chips to get the players they have
on their team now
it does not look very promising for them
in future draft picks or seasons
but
they have made it to their ultimate goal
especially the trade for matthew
stafford that was a huge decision yeah
and changed the course of the rams
yes trading matthew stafford for a giant
yeti was probably a controversial move
to say the least
all right let's see what's gonna happen
here
we've got the possibility of taking that
guy out and i think they're going to go
for it
[Music]
and whoa in a headbutt
knocked out of the game oh stomped by
the crowd to death to death
and the ball has made it
all the way over the ball went flying
that hit was so hard the ball just went
30 yards away yeah rado the beautiful is
going for it and she's picked it up
she's gonna hand it a hawk it off to
long bombed uh i'll coin the donner
whatever uh passed by that looks like a
great throw and it's cool
this could be another problematic
incident for the bengals here it seems
like nothing but misery experiences the
bengals every turn
sounds like the bengals of old if you
ask me oh jesse
jesse bates oh no not jesse basically
hurry hurry sign him this year and
instead he's he's gonna be out for the
count
yeah he's hopefully he can recover
before next season see the thing about
the super bowl is you're playing for
this year if you win the championship
the injuries don't mean that much to the
to the players unless it ruins their
career entirely
[Applause]
but if they get injured in the super
bowl the last game of the season and
it's a long recovery process they're
likely not going to be there for the
beginning of next season ah
interesting interesting good analysis
good analysis my friend good analysis so
staying healthy is still key if you want
hope for the next possible season ahead
all right if if miss butterfingers here
could just pick up the ball and she
can't
or can she
we're gonna re retry this pickup
she's got it
oh that's an impossible pass but she
could run it
she could run it up the right here
the left is probably the better player i
think the bengals have them a little
outflanked on the left side if they can
get far enough ahead and they have the
defenders in case there is a turnover
you might be right about that that's a
good point that's a good point she can
box in there and if she goes going for
it she could go the distance let's see
what happens
and she went for he holds on to the ball
it's john
it is incredible we love to see it now
we get a chance to see some action here
uh pushback's better than the no back am
i right am i right am i 100
100 right 100 right
is that a double hit there is that two
hits
is that two hits oh
with a double smackdown
and we're gonna bring up the bear's
gonna oh bear needs to take a big hit
there before we do anything so might as
well just take this guy out of here
yeah that's what we'd love to see and
destroys them
absolutely destroys we're gonna stay
behind just to run oh with a big left
hand
knocked down
all right we're gonna ring around the
rosie here
maybe not there
here
to there
to block it off
good dodge good dodge excellent dodge
we'd love to see it
all right and and trey henderson is
still drooling
still drooling positioning
is key in this moment they still have
the bengals have one player way deep
towards their end zone i wonder why
they're keeping them that far back maybe
it's just their super safety it's called
a safety
oh this does not look good for
butterfingers
looks
[Applause]
looks bad for joe mixon
[Applause]
looks like joe mixon is oh
knocked out look at the top teeth also
knocked out of the mouth in that
particular moment yeah that was brutal
we did i love to see it actually i i
really did ah we're gonna see joe burrow
come up for vengeance
let's see what he can do
oh oh
oh
oh come on all right both down it's
better than just me down oh
but that leaves oh no it doesn't turn
over yep but he's boxed in the body of
his companion is blocking his path from
them he cannot get there at all he can't
get there no he cannot
they're trying to box in jamar chase
tamar chase is getting surrounded but if
we've seen it before throughout the
season jamar chase has escaped greater
precarious situations than this oh
they're blitzing they're blitzing
butterfingers but it looks like it's
going to be a double down
ooh ball is free bangles have a chance
here all right maybe we could get some
action from uh
who just loves drooling he loves
drooling all right we might be able to
pick that up if it's a plus four it's
risky
we could try to go for this guy first
knock him out of the
way and he will
push him back oh push him towards the
ball hmm go this way
and then push him this way
ooh good calls good calls
good calls for a big ball it was a great
play here
it really was all right let's run them
this way and then let's keep it going
and what's what's even the danger what's
the danger is there any danger there's
no digging they're gonna go for it all
much like they have throughout the
entire season they gotta
all right let's see if we can get some
vengeance here
let's uh try to get
blitz
what if we just
no it's a plus six dodge it's gonna be
too risky are you still drooling you you
all right bud
come on come on you got all right he's
coming out
he stopped eating crayons long enough to
run down the field has done it
all right let's see what else trey
henderson can do i think that's all i
can do there all right and we got eretto
the beautiful still posing in the back
maybe moving them up field wouldn't it
be a bad decision nope
all right
oh and they just pushed him back that
might put him out of some of the danger
zone and it does they're still trying to
box up jamar chase they really want to
take out jamar chase you know i think
their focus is misguided here they know
what a danger is but they don't know
what a danger amazon say the yum
let's see if we can do a uh wait a nice
block yeah i think that's the good play
there let's try this first and yes
that's gonna be a pushback get them out
of the way so that we
stay behind and that way we can just
blitz you
all we need is twos all the way down
that's easy here he comes
oh he's right up in his grill oh and it
might be both players knocked down but i
we're gonna re-roll it
that's a big hit and the lead block
by jumper the quarterback
out of here
really pulling through for his teammate
here that's what we'd love to see in the
past it's completely open for a
touchdown and it's boom
[Applause]
bangle touchdown the bangles get a real
touchdown this time no fake touch
incredible
[Applause]
as much as i hate to say it i do miss
the green cheerleaders we saw earlier
today
something about these cheerleaders just
really don't do it for me unfortunately
the bengals did and get one player
injured ah but three knocked out for the
uh rams yes
uh i'd say that's a good trade like the
rams are bringing in their subs oh
they're they're doing a different
strategy they're gonna overload the left
side slightly here
how will the bengals match up i honestly
like their alignment to one extent but
they are
overpowered with the big i think
that's an aggressive positioning this is
aggressive positioning let's refine it a
little bit here
see the rams only have three people on
the line of scrimmage
makes it a interesting matchup i think
we're gonna swap out our bigs
so that we front load they they're gonna
front load yes they are they're gonna do
that you know i think there's an
advantage to having a slight gap because
if they try and run through or around
you cover more space and make them have
to dodge more you're correct about that
you are correct
[Applause]
that might have been an opportunity
there for a uh
oh we are the bengals it's a reverse
blitz
somehow it might have been an
opportunity to kick it short there and
make them have to face off with the ball
carrier against their pigs but bengals
elected not to go go for that strategy
ah yeah probably too many crayons never
going to be perfectly honest uh that's
not good for the brain that's only
hendrickson
yeah well he kind of is influential to
the rest of the team you know how it is
when one player does something the
others want to follow suit they see
performance they follow performance he
was a free agent signing this year and
he was considered uh one of the top pass
rushers uh throughout the 2021 season
you can see why a lot of calories in
crayons however lot of chemicals that
interfere with neurotransmitters
you know the bengals actually made some
incredible free agent signings this year
that have all been successful
wow bengals into halftime with a lead we
haven't seen that too often this season
no we have not uh even in the other
universes where we saw them play at
different versions much like doctor
strange looking into the future and it
seems the rams players have all
recovered their starters are back in
all right well it's okay for the bengals
because uh every single player on the
rams team is a clone of the other
all right looks like we've got defensive
setup too i think there might be an
adjustment to defensive setup too that
the bengals might go with here nope
all right
maybe there's a short kick strategy
they're gonna go for an on side kick
it's a surprise on side brilliant
coaching get an extra re-roll thanks to
coach taylor coach taylor with the uh oh
[Applause]
sorry
still resulted in a touchback
somehow somehow they're blocking up with
one but you still got one two three
people here able to come in oh there it
is they're really they're really
overpowering their left side of the
offense here they are they are but
there's gonna be an impenetrable wall of
meat that that runner has to get through
he's not gonna be able to slot any gaps
without risking ah they might be going
for a pass play here with one guy
interesting interesting interesting
oh no the hog molly up front might be
getting uh
the hero of last game as the decoy is
out for the count
oh no just stunned maybe he'll be able
to get back a little bit he is tough
he's tough that one all right let's see
what the bengals do here
bangles are going to do a lot
all right they have to use a re-roll but
it worked
and we'll move him to block up the other
guy we're gonna follow him
down with the knockout okay oh
complete ko let's get some of these guys
down here and open
i think this is a defensive positioning
not an offensive positioning but you
know the bengals know what they're doing
here bengals every position is potential
for anything you never know what to
expect from them they're going to do
anything at any time
maybe that player could be an assistant
to help the other player are not
yep it is the classic uh
setup
here he goes with the head to the
ground
to the
dick all right they're gonna button up
this so that there's no way to get
through
no way to pass
no chance for anything
perhaps they can take out that lead
blocker yeah and perhaps they will
and
pushed him back
they will push him back and if he
follows him he's going to be right next
to that ball handler
that's not going to look good for him be
here yeah yeah cover cover this the the
skirt around
yep and you're gonna plug the gap
this does not look good for that ball
handler i think they're good at dodging
they might be able to skirt around
or staying there in case the pass is
completed
that's true
that is true
all right interesting game interesting
game
let's see what the rams do here with
their ball carrier surrounded
their options are limited oh one guy got
back up sony mitchell too tough to keep
down
they're going for any moon let's see if
they stay standing no they will not they
will not the rams have knocked out
another bangle i heard her spine shatter
so that did not sound good she is in the
ground
mm-hmm she is completely almost six feet
under oh my god
oh mother bangle down from a massive ram
and another bone to never recover all
right but the battles have something in
store here with a big hit to the ball
carrier it could change the game
and will it the question is will it
uh please don't be a bonehead no come on
no no no trey stop eating crayons and
goddamn it he is eating crayons all
right let's see what uh bessie jates the
third can do and it'll just be a push
is not a bad play here
a double push back
push back can they fumble it can they
fumble it
no but not an opportunity for
the bengals to rush the ball carrier
there potentially yes they did but
that'd be a big dodge so why not let's
just go for a hit here possibly take
that spot take him out more like
beautifully done and is going to in fact
block the the ball carrier from going
around the other direction the only
problem here is now the bengals leave
themselves open to a deep pass
that is true that is true they are
completely open over here but you got to
remember the bangles completely open
here doing nothing to help the rest of
the team let's see what happens here
what are the rams going to do what are
the rams going on it looks like the rams
are trying to surround trey hendrickson
who's still eating his crayons he loves
those crayons man he is trying to
someone asked him to count what two plus
two means so you saw steam coming out
his ears he went back to the crayons
they're blitzing the catcher here they
are
oh and it's a double knockout oh
oh
she got revenge for her fellowship
is out for the game right in the groin
oh it's a big big groin strain big groin
strain here well the bengals have a
massive opportunity here if they can
take out the ball carrier this is a
massive opportunity here let's see
okay that's one dice this would be two
if we could get enough brain power to
actually hit
let's see if we can make something
happen
another groin head oh
he's down and the ball has disappeared
into the ether we'll see where the ball
goes it was a big hit
right there
oh he can't do anything
his brain is ill is incapable of
anything further however we can box up
that box
the box can be boxed up and send
somebody deep for the past could the
bengals throw a touchdown pass here
could they throw could they throw we
will have someone up there oh he's going
for it
if only someone there could pick up that
ball somebody could pick up that ball
hmm looks like uh trey hendricks's time
to shine to some
let's see and he
yes he can on to the jaws of death you
go
wham
look at that
look at that man
can any of the bengals players get up
that are their turn has not been used
yet that are laying on the ground uh not
yet not yet but we can do a little bit
of oopsies
there we go that's what we're doing
that's another knock down
with a big left hand oh yeah [ __ ]
slapped him down but still can't get
that ball it's all right because i don't
think the rams are going to be able to
can you click on one of those down
players for me and see if they're going
to stand
uh this one
he
oh the bangles oh no oh no no
they will not get up oh oh wait oh oh oh
that would be a hell of a gambit look at
this gambit look at that you know the
bengals have been risking it all year
they've been risking the side no no it
won't be enough distance well maybe okay
we could it could it could happen
it could happen oh it doesn't happen
first roll bad ooh
that's not what you're right the rams
are in danger territory here if the
banks are in danger they gotta go past
two players to even touch that ball uh
interesting i see what they're going for
the only thing they can they're going to
try to get these players out of the way
but it's a dependency on what they can
do
knock them right into the ball it's
interesting
[Applause]
they just didn't want joe burrow to
touch that ball that's what they didn't
want they are scared of joe burr
they're knocking him back
even more interesting pushing them
closer
all right
i think if joe burrow can take out that
defender on the right side there won't
even need to be a dodge
you're right about that let's see what
joe can do they forget that joe is
actually extremely powerful
and joey
ryan i guess
loves to devastate those balls did you
know that joe burrow last year
completely obliterate his knee in a
massive injury
and came back this year to be
frankly in contention for one of the
best players in the league in 2021 i did
not know that all right we got a plus
five dodge pickup going on here we got a
2005 dodge pickup i think the better
strategy is just to whack that guy
oh but he's still got
dodge you know maybe trey hendrickson
can take out somebody to reduce that
dodge or he can take out the dodge
person himself maybe
he might be able to still be a plus five
dodge on his i think the better strategy
is to try to hit this guy take his spot
get him out of the way or murder him or
he's gonna murder him he's
going to murder him
absolutely backhand uh crayon fueled
rage
that's still a plus five dodge maybe if
he takes out the guy who's forcing him
to dodge that could be beneficial i
think we'll wait a turn on that one he's
probably gonna wait a turn he's very
smart about his plays and uh this guy's
gonna clear up this interference here
uh and he called his mom a [ __ ] that
did not work out well ah well oh he got
angry about that one yep
oh yeah
that man's mom is a saint you do not say
otherwise
ooh and he can still blitz he's still
moon he's still mobile he could come
over here and stand in the way maybe the
run play is going to be the better play
in this situation yeah he's not going to
pick it up but he's going to look
menacingly daring sony mitchell to
insult his mother
just daring him let's see what the rams
do here
yeah
can play the clock well every single ram
is looking at that ball practically
salivating but they know that gambit
they gotta get back up they get back up
man these rams are tough they are
resilient to say brazilian uh-oh looks
like uh
he didn't he really truly thinks that
his mom's a [ __ ] and oh
god he has pictures of their evening
together in france you know we really
don't know we don't know that player's
mother so maybe she is maybe she is a
[ __ ] i mean i actually personally know
to their other player
interesting
apparently that's possible everybody
all right well the bengals have a chance
here
oh that'd be a place uh i think if
hendrickson takes out the man who's
forcing their middle guy to dodge that
might be the
strategy it might be the strat that
might be the strat let's see what goes
on here yeah that looks good we're gonna
use him to push
the backhand knocking him into his own
player
yes
he is open to rush for the ball if you
could just not go
let's see if we can push up some more
space here maybe
oh
[Music]
and they do successfully that's what we
call good
[Applause]
oh the headbutt
with the exterior teeth
rocking
yep that is what you love to see wonder
if uh it might be better for joe burrow
himself to come over and talk about
who's nope he's not gonna do that he
could take out the other defender though
that's right oh and he will let's see if
he's going to go for the dick once more
that is always his favorite move and
it's it is still consistent he's
consistent that's what you say about joe
burrow and now he's got a clear line of
sight to kill that ball carrier
[Music]
lethal it's lethal ladies and gentlemen
lethal with the lethal left hand oh and
that's
interesting oh it's right next to joe
burrow this might be the play for the
ages uh let's see what happens whoo
oh
run to the right side the right side is
open it is open but i think he's going
to stick by joe burrow just to be uh
like a protective mother bear
not a bad play not a bad player
not a bad player any of the bengals that
are knocked down get up like the rams it
does not seem possible it doesn't seem
that way they can you can
what he's been playing dead the whole
time
he's just been sleeping this whole time
he went wild
what
what you you they they've literally just
been taking a nap ladies and gentlemen
this is kind of a revelation here um
didn't
didn't know they could get up at any
moment that one's dead that that one is
dead
uh nope moe jackson's back up all of the
bengals are suddenly getting back up
it seems like that was just a thing you
could do at any moment in time
wow wish i would have known that earlier
his mother is still a [ __ ]
oh he got knocked down but he got up
again only get it knocked back down
oh you hate to see it you hate to see it
looks like the rams are getting into a
really uh nice defensive stance going
right down the middle of the bengals
setup
all right let's see these players that
got back up what they can do it's a
double knockout that's payback right
there and it's a turnover because of
that
oh that's gonna leave
this might be it ladies and gentlemen
what is happening he's a head took a few
too many hits to the dick
he's just
opponent today i think his his attitude
is just
you know
whatever it takes to win
whatever it takes to win that is true
and the lane is open
for the bengals to just run it down
field
all right let's see
betsy jates he can't go the distance he
can't do it but what he could do
what could happen
if this dodge happens if this dodge
makes it
if if nope that's more dangerous todd
yeah you know what
if if oh catcher
oh that would that wouldn't do anything
either yeah she goes deep she'll she'll
you can throw it forward
but i don't know if she could catch it
and then do anything i don't think she
can run afterwards now
maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
he is not a passer we know that about
him he is not a passer let's just see
yep let's just run him up the field and
uh see what he can do the next turn
he's
going for it
might as well
[Applause]
he's right by the end zone
all right let's take it let's see let's
oh god
[Applause]
well okay bengals have knocked
themselves down
[Music]
joe burrow could fricken do anything
which he can't oh joe burrow has had an
incredible season you can't
always count on him he's been consistent
he's been one of their clutch players
along with jamar chase tyler boyd t
higgins
you know
trey hendrickson and sam hubbard have
also been key players but when you get
that deep in the balls of the enemy it's
going to get to your head every once in
a while it is it is and they're blitzing
bessie jason obviously a quick way to
get cocky
oh they're going to knock him
but they're going to knock him into the
touchdown oh my gosh
jesse
touchdown
[Applause]
oh and here comes the inferior
cheerleaders
yeah they are not green we're getting
into the final few minutes of this game
the real bangles may have this locked
down they might got it locked down it
seems like they're going to go for an
onside kick again
let's see how it works out for him
quick snap
and the ball's right there
it's a chance man if the bengals are
able to score another touchdown there
this game's over it's one turn left they
would have to grab the ball and run it
all in the same turn they would have to
pick up the odell beckham senior and
just bring him in
trey hendrickson with his massive size
and his girthiness i think could pull it
off he might pull it off he might pull
that guy's head right off
oh they're trying to get jamar chase
down again he was taking a nap last turn
uh he's still energetic you can't keep
him down they're gonna be coming back
oh they're still gonna hit him this time
right to the gut i feel like there's
bullying at this point
well no i think that's a ram so it can't
be a bully
very funny very funny very funny thank
you put in the canned laughter for that
one
all right we'll do
actually let's see
let's see what he does
oh he does something all right i'll push
him right into the ball carrier i know
he unfortunately
cannot now hendricks then going for the
sack here
i wonder if he no six plus dodges that's
not gonna happen
but this will
all right
apparently
daryl henderson is out
brutal brutal well the bengals do have
an opportunity why are you going around
that way
maybe
maybe if they take out the guys on the
left hand there we go that's
why he's going for it
he's gonna make it oh
tripped up blow time
and it's an instant replay
terrible terrible terrible work but that
is a turnover but is that the end of the
game
that is the end of the game
and the bengals have
won all odds the real bengals have done
it the real whoa oh look at joe burrow
he's doing the gritty
you already hear right at the ball proud
stadium the id tournament
mvp's being
annie mon velasque
we really saw her performance
ah she got a level up oh i didn't know
that was a thing here all right well
didn't know they could even level up
that is interesting all right well i
mean as you play you you do get better
throughout your career from what i've
heard
that's why tom brady always won so many
games he's been in the league for so
many years
uh apparently you can level her up
infinitely
i could have made these guys better
all right well that's great
um this has all been one big ploy to
announce
our new podcast it's
really fun we have a great time because
we don't take sports too seriously but
also we take sports very seriously in
that tyler here knows
so much about sports he's a fountain of
knowledge and i am not
so if you want to know about sports or
even if you don't want to know about
sports and you just want to listen to me
and tyler laugh check the link in the
description go my favorite sports team
we also get off topic and talk about
anything under the sun i think we were
talking about tectonic plates at one
point
oh my god we were
but it's not like distractible we've got
a very cohesive formula we do it is we
do but it's also me and tyler talking so
who knows what could happen the focus is
still on sports but we you know
the horizons get broadened as we discuss
things and how
you know there's a flow there's a flow
yeah you'll understand it just listen
you'll understand yeah just give it a
listen just give one episode a listen
and make sure and hit the follow button
and get notifications for when new
episodes come out which they come out
every thursday
all right
okay and bye all right oh it's that dial
trail no well they shouldn't be here
anymore they should be listening to the
episode if they're
still here that means they're not
listening to the episode of the podcast
and they need to save it too and if
they're not here they clearly haven't
saved it yeah they haven't saved it yeah
they got to make it the number one
sports podcast you know that's on you
no that no that's on them
i'm talking to them oh
sorry
you should be
go listen to it link in the description
go click on it
[Music]
you